[Music]
it is an unclassified node and has been
for several years what the United States
spends on intelligence every year right
it's an unclassified number they don't
really break out what they're spending
you know for they break it out only in
terms of two categories general
intelligence and military intelligence
and the totals for you know for many
years now have been around seventy
billion dollars 7-0 billion dollars
seventy billion dollars about 20 billion
on for military which you know helps you
fight about 50 billion just because to
surveil the world right now I have to
say I'm skeptical right that we need to
spend seventy billion dollars on
intelligence I am skeptical about what
some of this intelligence is buying and
doing all right I'm skeptical right
intelligence in general is what you need
for defense or offense you need it for
restraint you need it for a Germany
right intelligence you need to run a
great power strategy but I'd like to
unpack what it is we're doing a little
bit better and look at some of these
activities and ask is this really
necessary because my impression is we
pretty much spy on everything given the
chance right friends enemies whomever
you know during the peak of our 9/11
anger and hurt we spied on ourselves
right and we spied on ourselves without
really sorting out the legal
ramifications of it we collected vast
amounts of metadata stored it this is
spying on Americans right now we're
doing a little bit less of it now but
it's not very hard for an American who
has friends abroad to get caught up in
surveillance right there's just a lot of
collection a lot of collection right and
a lot of this information is stored so
that if something happens the I see you
using fancy algorithms can backtrack
communications among individuals to
figure out who is in
located and who knew who write if you
have the big library and you have the
guilty party
you can then reverse engineer to try and
figure out who else was implicated it
doesn't prevent the terrorist attack
when it does allow you to prosecute the
group but all the rest of us end up
compromising our privacy for this
purpose right and we have to we should
this is another thing where we should
have a conversation right and it's not a
easy and straightforward conversation
because some people would privilege
safety and say fine they can have that
metadata on me right the the the traffic
the numbers I called as long as they're
not collecting the text of my phone
calls they can collect the origins of my
phone calls and emails keep them in a
library anonymized until they need to D
an itemized them some people would say
fine if that's what we need to be able
to backtrack a terrorist event and break
up a network I'm they're fine with that
I'm a little uncomfortable with it I
have to say right but I don't think it's
an open-shut straightforward matter I
think this is these things about the
magnitude of the American intelligence
effort worldwide what the what that
effort is focusing on how much
information its ends up collecting at
home
right this is something that really
needs to be discussed because it I think
it has something to do with American
liberties right and so you know this is
not particularly what I spend my days
doing but I do have some I do feel
uneasy about it and and I I do tend to
believe that the more active we are in
international politics the more this
machine grinds on the more we collect
abroad the more we're going to collect
at home and the bigger the kind of
amorphous mass of information waiting to
be misused by someone is right and
that's the thing that kind of concerns
me
[Music]